>> SAYING RUSSIA WILL, NOT,
DICTATE THE SECURITY ASSISTANCE
THAT WE SUPPLY TO UKRAINE.
THE COMMENTS A RESPONSE TO
RUSSIAN THREATS --
AFTER CNN ALLIES REPORTED THE
U.S. IS FINALIZING PLANS TO
SEND THE PATRIOT MISSILE
DEFENSE SYSTEM TO UKRAINE,
TODAY, TOP UKRAINIAN MILITARY
OFFICIALS SAY LOOK RUSSIA
LAUNCHED 41 MISSILE ATTACKS,
AND 32 DRONE ATTACKS IN THE
LAST WEEK.
CNN SENIOR INTERACTION --
WILL RIPLEY IS IN UKRAINE FOR
MORE.
>> ANDERSON, EVEN BEFORE AN
OFFICIAL WHITE HOUSE
ANNOUNCEMENT ON PATRIOT MISSILE
DEFENSE SYSTEMS COMING TO
UKRAINE, THE RUSSIANS, WHETHER
IT EMBASSY IN D.C., OR THE
KREMLIN OR ALREADY QUICKLY
RESPONDING SAYING THE EMBASSY
SAYING THAT THERE WILL BE
UNPREDICTABLE CONSEQUENCES IF
THE PATRIOTS WERE TO ARRIVE ON
THE GROUND IN UKRAINE.
THE KREMLIN SAYING THEY WILL
BECOME LEGITIMATE TARGETS.
ALTHOUGH, IT'S UNKNOWN IF THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO FIND THEM AND
OR HIT THAT.
WITH THE UKRAINIANS HAVING
SAYING THAT FOR MONTHS OR YEARS,
AS THEY NEED THE WEAPON SYSTEM
AS OF LATE TO DEFEND AGAINST
THE CONSTANT RUSSIAN
BOMBARDMENT OF THE CIVILITY IN
POWER INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS
DESIGNED TO INFLICT SUFFERING
ON MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ACROSS
UKRAINE WHO ARE LIVING IN THE
DARK AND COLD RIGHT NOW,
CERTAINLY, THAT IS A SITUATION
FOR THOSE WHO REMAIN IN KHERSON.
THE FRONT LINES OF THE SOUTH,
THE CITY WHICH WAS OCCUPIED BY
THE RUSSIANS THE TARGET OF
CONSTANT ONSLAUGHT OF SHELLING
THAT HAS NOT ONLY KILLED PEOPLE
AND DESTROYED MUCH OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BUILDING, BUT
HAS ALSO, YOU KNOW, THIS
CONNECTED THE CITY FROM THE
POWER GRID.
AND THEN TO THE EAST, THERE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A FIERCE FIGHTING,
THE RUSSIANS TRYING TO TAKE
BACK THE CITY OF --
AND UKRAINIANS FIRING DOZENS OF
ROCKETS AT RUSSIAN TERRITORY,
THE RUSSIAN DESCRIBED IT AS THE
WORST ATTACK ON DONETSK SINCE
2014.
SOME EIGHT YEARS.
CNN CAN'T INDEPENDENTLY VERIFY
ALL THE RUSSIAN ACTS, BUT
SOCIAL MEDIA VIDEOS HAVE
EMERGED SHOWING BUILDING ON
FIRE, THE RUSSIANS CLAIMING A
CATHEDRAL WAS HIT.
CLEANING BOTH --
THERE WAS A MAJOR INTERSECTION
THAT WAS SET ABLAZE.
AND THE ECONOMIST, UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS ARE SIGNALING THEY
THINK THE RUSSIANS COULD BE
PREPARING A MAJOR ATTACK ON THE
CAPITAL KYIV SOMETIME EARLY
NEXT YEAR.
THIS COMES WITH THE CAVEAT THAT
THE RUSSIANS AND UKRAINIANS
HAVE BOTH DELIBERATELY USED THE
INFORMATION TO THEIR ADVANTAGE.
SOMETIMES MISINFORMATION
DELIBERATELY PUTTING OUT THERE
TO THROW OFF THE OTHER SIGN.
THAT SAID, THE HEAD OF
UKRAINE'S ARMED FORCES SAY THAT
HE BELIEVES RUSSIA MIGHT BE
PREPARING 200,000 FRESH TROOPS,
HE SAYS HE HAS NO DOUBT THEY
WILL MAKE A MOVE ON KYIV AT
SOME POINT.
AND OF THE REASON WHY A LOT OF
TRAINING AND LOTS OF
PREPARATION IS NEEDED BY THE
UKRAINIANS, BUT THEY CONTINUE,
AT THIS MOMENT, TO FIGHT ON THE
FRONT LINES, HOLD THE LINES,
AND PREPARE FOR WHATEVER MAY BE
COMING DOWN THE ROAD.
>> WILL RIPLEY, APPRECIATE IT.
>> YOU ARE THE REPORTS FROM
WILL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE RUSSIAN
--
WHY DO YOU THINK THE RUSSIANS
ARE ISSUING THESE THREATS ON
THE PATRIOTS WHEN THEY PLAN TO
USE IT FOR THE DEFENSE?
>> THEY DON'T WANT THE PATRIOT
INSIDE OF UKRAINE ANYTIME SOON.
THEY KNOW THAT WOULD BE THE
CAPABILITY THAT WOULD COUNTER
ANY LONG RANGE STRIKE
CAPABILITY THAT THE RUSSIANS
HAVE.
WHAT I AM TALKING ABOUT THEIR,
THEY HAVE BEEN LAUNCHING
MULTIPLE MISSILES AND ROCKETS
FROM LONG RANGE BOMBERS THAT
WERE OUTSIDE THE AREA OF
OPERATIONS.
THEY KNOW THAT THESE PATRIOTS
SYSTEMS NOT ONLY HAVE A GREATER
ALTITUDE TO SHAKE TARGETS IN
THE AIR, BUT A LONGER RANGE,
THEY CANNOT ONLY HIT INCOMING
MISSILES WITH DIFFERENT TYPES
OF AMMUNITION, BUT THEY CAN
ALSO HIT THESE LONG RANGE
BOMBERS.
IT CAUSES THE RUSSIANS TO GO
FURTHER OUT.
THIS IS ALL PART OF THE
DEFENSIVE CAPABILITY OF UKRAINE
TO CONTINUE TO PUSH THE
RUSSIANS BACK SO THEY DON'T
CONTINUE TO STRICT THE CITIZENS
OF THE COUNTRY.
>> A SPOKESPERSON FROM THE
PENTAGON SAID TODAY, WE WILL
NOT ALLOW COMMENTS FROM RUSSIA
TO DICTATE THE SECURITY SYSTEMS
WE PROVIDE TO YOU.
DO YOU EXPECT THE PENTAGON, DO
YOU EXPECT THEM ACTUALLY TO
DEPLOY PATRIOTS, WE DISCUSSED
AS A COUPLE OF TIMES, JUST THE
COST OF THE SYSTEMS THEMSELVES,
THE COST OF EACH INDIVIDUAL
PATRIOT MISSILE.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO HIT A
DRONE THAT YOU SAID CAN COST
$20,000.
>> THEY WON'T BE HITTING THE
DRONES.
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION FIRST,
ANDERSON, YES, DO I EXPECT THEM
TO DEPLOY SOME OF THEM?
YES.
DO EXPECT THEM TO BE ON THE
GROUND AN OPERATIONAL WITHIN
WEEKS?
NO I DO NOT.
BECAUSE I KNOW IT TAKES --
YOU WILL NOT HAVE AMERICANS
FIRING THE SYSTEMS INSIDE OF
UKRAINE, OR MAINTAINING, THEM
OR REPAIRING THEM.
THEY HAVE TO TEACH THE
UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS TO DO THIS.
AS WE TALKED SO MANY TIMES
BEFORE.
THIS IS A VERY COMPLEX SYSTEM.
THESE KIND OF MISSILES WON'T BE
USED AGAINST THESE DRONES.
THEY WILL BE USED AGAINST THE
LONGER RANGE AND HIGHER
ALTITUDE TARGETS, WHICH WILL
ALLOW UKRAINE TO SHIFT SOME OF
THE OTHER LOW ALTITUDE,
MID-ALTITUDE AREA DEFENSE
SYSTEMS AGAINST THE DRONE IN
THE INCOMING ROCKETS.
IT JUST GIVES SOMETHING A NEW
TYPE OF AMMUNITION THAT THE
UKRAINIANS CAN USE IN THEIR KIT
BAG.
WHEN YOU ASK, DO I EXPECTED TO
BE ANYTIME SOON?
ANDERSON, WE ARE FACING A
SITUATION RIGHT NOW IN WARFARE,
I WILL SIMPLIFY WHAT BILL JUST
SAID.
WARFARE IS MADE OF CONSTANT
SHIFTING BETWEEN OFFENSE AND
DEFENSE.
FORCES ARE EITHER IN THE ATTACK
WHERE THE DEFENSE.
RUSSIA IS ATTEMPTING TO GO BACK
ON THE ATTACK, THEY HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO DO IT, THEY HAVE
BEEN ON THE DEFENSE FOR TWO
MONTHS WHILE THEY HAVE BEEN
HINTING UKRAINIANS, CIVILIANS
WITH ROCKETS.
THEY WANT TO GO BACK AND REGAIN
TERRITORY FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS.
UKRAINE WANTS TO CONTINUE WITH
THEIR OFFENSIVE, BUT THE
OFFENSIVE OPERATION TAKES A LOT
MORE PEOPLE AND A LOT MORE
LOGISTICS.
IT'S GOING TO BE EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT FOR BOTH OF THEM TO
TRANSITION UKRAINE I